james jones asks do you have any ideas
on using neuralink or any other brain
software interfaces in the future
no i mean with that kind of thing
what you have in your mind right now is
like what you imagine it might be like
you don't know what it's going to be
like right and you can't design for
something unless you know what it is so
we just have to see
okay ein ethne says oh exciting as i'm a
software engineer question for him do
you use machine learning and or ai
development when working on game design
and development if so how
not on any current projects there's one
that we were doing um
for a little bit but
it turned out we were working on too
many things at once so that's on pause
right now but we were using it to uh try
and generate
facial animation from uh vocal tracks so
a little bit the opposite of what i was
talking about before but like if you
have a voice actor read some lines and
it's well acted and all that stuff now
you want the character on the screen to
like say the lines and have their face
move in the right way there's
historically you might try to record
that by having the actor like wear all
this stuff
and then
you know but but there's a lot of
drawbacks to that um so we were like hey
can we just generate the animation and
we had uh some beginning of that but we
hadn't gotten very far before we pushed
pause on the project
there's this great youtube channel
called two minute papers
do you subscribe to it
no but i've seen a couple of them i
think man like every week or so it makes
me wonder man the implications of this
for game development but it's also like
you hear about there's a pill that works
in rats such that they can eat as much
food as they want and they don't get
fat and then you'll then you wonder well
man that'll be great once it comes to
humans and then it does wait a long time